thank
you I live in Texas I'm originally from
California and I know we vote very
differently yes between I hope that
you're not one of those who comes from
California and brings your politics here
cuz you left for a reason right living
in the Bible Belt I've seen yeah you
know how that can affect people um I've
seen how it affects me as a black person
112% so so I literally went to a
restaurant when I was 8 years old and
they told my cheerleading coach that I
couldn't go into their restaurant
because I was black and I was in Texas
and it would never happen in cforia so
there's just things definitely happens
in
California okay oh yeah I appreciate
talking California this is really fun no
you saying no racist in California come
on there's no way ever been to
Venice I've seen some I Liv in
California too I definitely SE I've seen
racist everywhere yeah yeah definitely
some neo-nazis in
California thank
you